A fan-favorite theater troupe, a scene that
explains the title, and a hair metal power
fantasy all kids can relate to.
"Thor: Love and Thunder" is one bombastic
Marvel movie, but these are the scenes that
most deserve a second watch.
Warning: major spoilers ahead.
The opening to "Thor: Love and Thunder" is
interesting for how different it starts from
the usual Marvel movies.
For one, it is practically silent at the beginning,
and there's no Marvel logo or fanfare.
The movie simply begins.
It's a disorienting shot of the desert.
As the camera rises and turns, we meet Christian
Bale as Gorr.
Just like in the comics that inspired the
film, Gorr is just a desperate father seeking
help from his god to save his child.
It's uncharacteristically somber and does
an excellent job of pulling you in.
It also sets up a strange connection between
this film and "Star Trek V: The Final Frontier."
That film also opens with a weathered bald
man in the desert.
Also, Gorr's goal is to reach the center of
the universe and have his wish granted by
the entity referred to as Eternity.
That sounds suspiciously like Spock's half-brother
Sybok's plan to meet God at the center of
the galaxy.
Coincidence?
Perhaps.
Watch both openings again, though, and you
might see the connection.
All the high-flying, wacky adventure stuff
you would expect from a Guardians of the Galaxy
and Thor team-up occurs after Gorr's origin
and a quick rundown of the previous film.
We learn that Thor is done wandering around
the cosmos looking for people to save.
Instead, he will sit and wait for someone
to say that they need his help to win this
battle.
"Well, you know what they say, better late
than not at all."
"That's very nice."
Peter Quill says those exact words, and Thor
rides on his ax Stormbreaker like the Wicked
Witch in "The Wizard of Oz" before single-handedly
defeating the enemy.
It is a bonkers sequence filled with humor
and incredible action.
It's got lasers, Guns N' Roses, Jim Henson-esque
creatures laughing and firing at Thor, a Jean-Claude
Van Damme split, and it's a lot of fun.
Watching this sequence is like seeing every
'80s and early '90s nerd's dream of what a
"Thor" movie should be come to life.
It isn't particularly insightful about the
human condition, and it doesn't break a lot
of new ground regarding superhero action,
but it's an absolute blast.
Why wouldn't you want to relive such a wild
and invigorating sequence more than once?
Jane Foster isn't holding up so well in "Thor:
Love and Thunder."
She's still a brilliant scientist using her
intelligence to try and save the world, but
she has also been diagnosed with stage IV
cancer.
Her old friends Darcy and Selvig are the only
ones who know about her illness, and Darcy
thinks Jane should reach out to Thor.
While Jane doesn't want to do that, Thor's
broken hammer Mjolnir is calling out to her.
Jane travels to New Asgard in Norway to find
the hammer.
While she's there, Asgardian actors, just
like in "Thor: Ragnarok," are performing a
scene from the previous movie.
They're doing Odin's death scene and using
every cheap stage production trick they can
think of to pull it off.
The scene is worth a second viewing because
it is hilarious, especially when Melissa McCarthy
arrives as Hela, and because it reminds viewers
that when an Asagardian dies and enters Valhalla,
they disappear in wisps of gold.
This time, you can take in the funny performances
and appreciate the foreshadowing of what will
happen in the final act with Jane.
Thanks to the trailers, it comes as no surprise
that Natalie Portman's Jane Foster would be
wielding the power of Thor in the film.
However, the anticipation for this moment
is so intense and the scene itself has so
much going on that when it finally happens,
you're thrilled.
"Jane?"
The acceleration of the sequence is what really
stands out.
It begins with Gorr arriving at New Asgard.
Using his new powers, he creates shadow creatures
that eerily stretch all along the Asgardian
streets.
When they start attacking, Thor, Korg, and
King Valkyrie are there to fight them off.
During the battle, Thor hears a familiar sound.
Looking around the chaos of battle, he sees
his reconstructed Mjolnir.
Just as the hammer is about to reach his hand,
it flies back to its current master: Jane
Foster.
Things turn into a violent and epic romantic
comedy as the two banter a bit before Gorr
goes on the attack.
Then we learn this was all a ruse for Gorr
to capture the children and hide them in the
Shadow Realm.
The seamless tonal shifts are very impressive,
and the moment Jane holds Mjolnir is a stand
up and clap moment.
With Thanos, Marvel created someone who was
multidimensional with a point of view you
could understand, even though you probably
don't agree with him.
They've done this again in "Thor: Love and
Thunder" in the form of Gorr the God Butcher.
From his first appearance, you understand
why he is so angry and vengeful.
He was clearly a devoted disciple of a god
who betrayed him with indifference.
That would be enough for us to understand
him, but we empathize because he is so complicated.
On a visual level, he looks haunted and creepy.
However, Christian Bale's voice isn't heavy,
deep, or raspy.
In a few scenes, his voice is high-pitched,
almost wounded.
For instance, take the scene in which he emerges
from the shadows, intentionally terrifying
the children he's captured by producing a
creature and ripping its head off in a horrifying
display of dominance.
He doesn't smile, he doesn't laugh.
Instead, he looks sad, tired, and confused.
It's worth watching again for the shock of
how dark the moment is and to savor the nuances
of the performance.
Since Gorr exists in the Shadow Realm, Thor
and friends need to borrow Zeus' weapon, Thunderbolt,
to fight the darkness.
This brings them to the incredible Omnipotence
City where all the gods reside.
Everything about this place deserves a rewatch
because it is so beautiful and packed with
Easter eggs and references that only multiple
viewings can fully reveal.
"Let's see who you are and take off your disguise."
The star of the show, though, is Russell Crowe
as Zeus.
To call his performance over the top would
be an understatement.
He is devouring the scenery around him like
an all-you-can-eat buffet and clearly loving
every second of it.
In a film this wacky, though, it absolutely
works, and Crowe is an utter delight.
During their visit to Omnipotence City, our
heroes discover that Gorr's goal is to make
it to the center of the universe in order
to reach a being called Eternity.
The legend says that the first person to reach
Eternity will have their wish granted.
Since Gorr's title is God Butcher, Valkyrie
implies that his wish would be to wipe all
gods out of existence.
So, they journey to the Shadow Realm to save
the children and stop Gorr from getting his
wish.
In a quest story, this would usually be the
part where everything slows down and the audience
gets a little bored waiting for something
to happen.
"Thor: Love and Thunder" keeps things interesting
by giving us cosmic vistas with space dolphins,
some world-building regarding the reproductive
process of Korg's species, and a warm heart-to-heart
between Thor and Jane.
Upon arriving in the Shadow Realm, all the
color drains out of the film, except for Thunderbolt,
which still crackles and sizzles with Zeus'
power.
The ominous nature of this mysterious place
sets in right away, and Thor's friends are
on the lookout for an ambush or any signs
of the children they're looking for.
While journeying through the tunnels deep
within the dark moon, Jane uncovers Gorr's
plan.
He needs Stormbreaker to conjure the Bifrost
in order to open the gates to Eternity.
Which kind of makes sense considering how
powerful the bridge is according to Heimdall.
"To leave the bridge open would unleash the
full power of the Bifrost and destroy Jotunheim
with you upon it."
The fact that kidnapping the Asgardian children
was all a ruse isn't surprising, but that's
not the point of the scene.
The reason this moment is so powerful is witnessing
just how brutal Gorr can be.
He moves through the shadows like a reanimated
corpse.
He speaks through sharp, rotten teeth, and
even tortures Thor to make him call his ax.
Some viewers may not wish to relive such an
aggressively dark scene, but the strength
of the performances should be enough to bring
you back.
There was a time when the primary audience
for superhero stories was kids.
Adult fans may not like to admit this fact,
but it's true.
As new creators entered the comic book industry,
they started updating their stories to reflect
their interests and, eventually, superhero
comics matured to a point where most parents
probably wouldn't allow their kids to read
them until reaching some mutually agreed-upon
age.
We have lived in this paradigm for so long
that it's easy to forget the more innocent
origins of our favorite characters.
Family and kid-friendly comics still exist,
of course, but the vast majority of superhero
films are aimed at older audiences.
That is why it is so rewarding when Thor shares
his powers with the kidnapped children.
For the first time in an MCU movie, we see
kids take on the bad guys, and it is pure,
thrilling wish fulfillment.
As the song "November Rain" kicks into gear,
the kids strike back.
Lightning erupts from their eyes and weapons
as they defeat their captors and Thor does
battle with Gorr.
For anyone who fell in love with superheroes
at a young age, this is a dream come true.
Like the opening, the ending of "Thor: Love
and Thunder" is surprisingly lacking in the
epic battle sequence department.
Marvel films have a habit of ending with two
superpowered beings punching each other into
exhaustion, and the one left standing is the
victor.
But "Love and Thunder" begins its climax that
way before careening into uncharted territory
for the MCU.
Gorr reaches Eternity.
Jane is succumbing to her illness, and Thor
doesn't know quite what to do.
Losing the love of his life and witnessing
her make the ultimate heroic sacrifice, he
decides to open his heart to Gorr.
As a result, Gorr doesn't wish for the end
of the gods, like he'd planned.
Instead, Eternity brings his daughter back.
Thor, inspired by the villain's drive to honor
his daughter at all costs, proves to him that
the reason for living has always been love.
If you're tired of loud, raucous, and tedious
finales, this ending should come as a breath
of fresh air, and is well worth a second viewing.
At the very least, it should help explain
to any confused viewers why the film is called
"Love and Thunder."
Everyone knows to stick around during the
credits of a Marvel movie.
Since Nick Fury introduced himself to Tony
Stark at the end of the original "Iron Man,"
it has become a tradition with each installment
to stay in your seat and see what tease they
have in store for the next movie.
In the case of "Thor: Love and Thunder," we
get two scenes.
One lets us know that Jane made it to Valhalla
where she is greeted by Heimdall.
The other sets up a very exciting antagonist
for the next film.
The scene begins with a wounded Zeus lamenting
people's lack of interest in the gods.
He can remember a time when humans feared
and worshiped them.
Now, all they care about are superheroes.
Fed up with this fall from grace, he vows
to make them fear the gods once again.
The suggestion that a new "Thor" movie featuring
gods terrorizing humanity is cool enough,
but the final reveal is the real kicker.
It turns out that Zeus wasn't simply talking
to himself — he was giving orders to his
son Hercules.
Then we see that Brett Goldstein, who played
Roy Kent in "Ted Lasso," is playing the legendary
son of Zeus.
Watching the son of Odin and the son of Zeus
duke it out is going to be a blast, and this
scene builds the hype perfectly.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.